yeah hello and welcome to this
announcement video something special
coming up and it is this sunday like
tomorrow from this video first posted
yeah it's a nice blitz match and it kind
of back to the roots of YouTube yeah
youtube lips with commentary we've got
ya kingscrusher playing me yes triathlon
is going to challenge me to a blitz
match we're going to play five and five
minutes games and five three-minute
games three minutes blitz and the
commentary and this is something special
will not be provided by one of us but it
will be a commentary by grandmaster so
somebody who's actually probably seeing
all our mistakes and trying to point
them out to you grandmaster rule in
hearts we from israel is going to do the
live commentary on the channel here of
the internet chess club yeah check the
link I've got the link in the
description and I'm also going to put it
yeah into the outro the video so you can
just click on it going to be fun sunday
the 29th and it will be nine in the
evening Central Europe in turn makes it
makes a three year in the evening US
East Coast yeah join the best challenge
is going to be fun bye bye until then